from Rocky's greatest enemies to his
closest friends the rocky franchise is
full of screen Legends who have passed
on too soon here are all the actors from
the films we've lost actor Tony Burton
is famous for playing trainer and Corner
Man Tony Juke Evers for Apollo and Rocky
Burton's Juke first appears in Rocky as
Apollo's rough and tough trainer who
helps him battle Rocky in the famous
heavyweight match at the end of the
first film as well as a rematch in Rocky
2 Burton also reprises his role in Rocky
Balboa before becoming an actor Burton
was also a boxer himself winning the
Flint Golden Gloves title in both
1955 and
1957 when Burton passed in 2016 both
Sylvester Stallone and Cole weathers
took to social media to note their
appreciation of the actor Stallone
posted a photo on Instagram of them
together on set and weathers wrote on X
sad news his intensity and Talent helped
make the Rocky movies
successful appearing in Rocky 5 as Rocky
jior Sage Salone got his first acting
credit and broke into the entertainment
business in 1990 Dad how you feeling
well I got a fun new dance how you doing
at school I made the Honor all you're
beautiful Sage would acted multiple
movies after Rocky 5 including daylight
and mosow zero typically performing in
the horror genre but also doing some
shorts as well it was reported that Sage
turned down the opportunity to play Rock
Jun again in Rocky Balboa due to wanting
to focus on other aspects of his career
in 2012 Sage Stallone passed away
suddenly at 36 due to atherosclerosis
which caused a heart attack according to
the Los Angeles County coroners veteran
actor Burgess Meredith famously known
for his role as Rocky's first trainer
Mickey goldmill in Rocky Rocky 2 and
Rocky 3 passed away in 1997 at the age
of 89 his character died years before
the actor's passing as Mickey has lost
during the events of Rocky 3 in
1982 although he appeared again in
flashbacks during Rocky 5 in 1990
Meredith was in his 60s during the
filming of Rocky in
1976 and had already been a working
actor during Hollywood's Golden Age long
before that Meredith also played the
famous role of the penguin in the 1966
Batman TV series starring Adam West and
Bert Ward's Dynamic doer he also starred
as Harry in 1941's Tom Dick and Harry
and has been nominated for two Academy
Awards including one for best actor in a
supporting role in Rocky needless to say
Meredith was a legend in the industry
and as he did with previous colleagues
sylvesta Stallone wrote about his love
for his co-star even long after his
death in 2017 Stallone shared a photo of
himself with maridi on Facebook stating
I love this guy and miss him very much
another notable will L from the original
Rocky film is actor Thea David who plays
the fight promoter miles Jurgens AKA The
Man responsible for organizing the first
fight between Rocky and Apollo Davis's
role as Jurgens is crucial to the
evolution of the rocky films that follow
David like bures Meredith was a veteran
actor already when he appeared in Rocky
he played the part of count sakam in the
original Journey to the Center of the
Earth in
1959 among other Classics Rocky serves
as one of David's final supporting roles
in a feature film before his death in
1978 before Rocky becomes a full-time
fighter he is a struggling young man in
Philadelphia working sketchy jobs in
order to make ends meet one particular
job is roughing up people who owe money
to Joe spinels Tony Gazo we meet Gazo
and Rocky after Rocky lets a guy off
easy for not paying up you didn't break
this guy's stom like I told you how do
you know I didn't break you don't think
I hear things Gazo appears in Rocky 2 as
well
attempting to get Rocky to invest in
real estate although Rocky refuses and
puts poly onto it instead Gazo is a
complicated character as he comes off as
a lowlife criminal but also seems to
care for Rocky even loaning him money to
take Adrien out to dinner although it is
never officially stated in the Rocky
franchise what happens to Gazo after
Rocky 2 the novelization of Rocky 4
notes that he's killed at some point
before the film spanel was an actor who
had roles in a few iconic films over the
197 s and 1980s including the Godfather
The Godfather Part Two and taxi driver
he passed in 1989 at age 52 due to
undetermined causes known for her role
as Mary and Creed the wife of Apollo
Creed in both Rocky 2 and Rocky 4
actress Sylvia Ms passed away in 2011 at
67 years old Mary am Bears witness to
everything that Apollo does to fight
Rocky train and then go up against Ivan
in Drago but unfortunately her husband
dies in the ring other than her roles in
Rocky 2 and Rocky 4 Ms only had two
other acting credits professional boxer
Thomas David Morrison appeared in Rocky
5 as Tommy Gun the aspiring young bugar
whom Rocky trains that is until Tommy
turns on him for the fame and fortune
that comes as being a champion this
eventually leads to a street fist fight
between the two which Rocky wins
Morrison's role in Rocky 5 was one of
his only credits as an actor as he is
more known for his actual boxing career
Morrison held the world boxing
organization title in 1993 after
fighting George Foreman he had a minor
comeback in the mid 2000s eventually
retiring in 2008 the boxer spend most of
his retirement with family before
falling ill and passing away in 2013 at
the age of
44 while roles in films including
Chinatown and Once Upon a Time in
America in addition to numerous
television Parts solidify him as one of
the more recognizable character actors
of the 1970s Bert young will be most
remembered for playing Rocky flaw but
well-meaning brother-in-law paully young
appeared in all five of the original run
of Rocky films as well as 2006's legacy
sequel Rocky bboa according to an
anecdote reprinted by The Hollywood
Reporter Sylvester Stallone personally
sought out young a one-time real life
boxer to play poly and the authenticity
of Stallone's writing instantly captured
Young's attention and interest young
said in an interview with the sweet
science I thought the script had the
cleanest Street Pros I'd ever read
Stallone is not only a workaholic he's a
genius who is always looking 3 years
ahead he has a real eyeball for what's
going on in the world you want the
bird go in the alley and eat the bird
Young's work on Rocky earned him a best
actor in a supporting role nomination at
the 1977 Oscars he passed away on
October 8th 2023 at the age of 83
Sylvester Stallone famousy based Rocky
on the 1975 fight between little known
New Jersey fighter Chuck webner and
heavyweight champ Muhammad Ali but while
the character of Rocky bore little
resemblance to his offscreen inspiration
there was no mistaking Apollo Creed
played by actor and former pro football
player kle weathers for anyone but the
greatest himself that's the way I see it
and that's the way it's going to be
possessing the real life Ali's handsome
powerful physique and Gift of Gab
weathers was a perfect fit for the role
and reprised it in three sequels though
Apollo Creed was arguably his most
famous role wethers was a fixture of
film and television for decades starring
in 1980s Classics like predator and
Action Jackson and gleefully parading
his Macho Persona in comedies like Happy
Gilmore and Arrested Development you
take this home throw it in a pot add
some broth the potato baby you got a
stew going he also stepped behind the
camera on occasion building up a solid
resume as a television director
including two episodes of the Disney
plus hit the Mandalorian in which he
also had an Emy nominated supporting
role sadly weathers died in his sleep in
February
[Music]